-This week, President Trump
violated the Iran deal,
and a CIA director was grilled
under past involvement
in torture.
Meanwhile, Trump supporters
were calling for him
to win the Nobel Peace Prize.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump's attempts
at diplomacy with North Korea
are a positive development.
And if the North and South
manage to broker
a peace deal with Trump's help,
that would be historic.
But now some people
are taking it five steps further
and insisting that Trump
deserves the Nobel Peace Prize,
and he was asked about it
yesterday at the White House.
-Everyone thinks so,
but I would never say it.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I want to do?
I want to get it finished.
The prize I want
is victory for the world.
-Victory for the world?
[ Laughter ]
He doesn't sound
like a Nobel laureate.
He sounds like a movie president
fighting an alien invasion.
[ Laughter ]
"I want victory for the world
against the space bugs,
one of whom
won't leave me alone."
[ Laughter ]
Shoo, space bug!"
And, again, diplomacy
with North Korea is good,
but this is still the same guy
who wanted to ban Muslims,
called Mexicans rapists,
said we should
kill the families of terrorists,
and said
he wanted fewer immigrants
from Africa and Haiti.
If he won a Nobel, his speech
would be the first in history
with an NC-17 rating.
[ Laughter ]
But, okay, let's hear budding
Nobel laureate Donald Trump
answer questions in detail
about his upcoming summit
with North Korean Leader
Kim Jong-un.
-Everything can be scuttled.
Everything can be scuttled.
Doesn't mean --
A lot of things can happen.
A lot of good things can happen.
A lot of bad things can happen.
-Wow. Soaring words.
You get a more specific answer
from Gmail's auto-reply.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also, there's a chance
he doesn't know
what "scuttle" means.
[ Laughter ]
"Anything can be scuttled.
Bananas."
[ Laughter ]
"Sidewalks --
you can scuttle them."
And on the same day
Trump was asked about
the Nobel Peace Prize,
his nominee for CIA Director,
Gina Haspel,
was being grilled in the Senate
over her role
in the CIA's torture program,
including the time she ran
a CIA black site in Thailand,
where detainees
were waterboarded
in violation
of U.S. and international law.
Yesterday, Haspel
was repeatedly pressed
on whether torture was immoral,
and she refused
to answer the question.
-Do you believe
that the previous
interrogation techniques
were immoral?
-Senator, I believe
that CIA officers
to whom you referred --
-It's a yes-or-no answer.
-Do you believe, in hindsight,
that those techniques
were immoral?
-Senator, what I believe,
sitting here today,
is that I support
the higher moral standard
we have decided
to hold ourselves to.
-Can you please
answer the question?
-Senator, I think
I've answered the question.
-No, you've not.
-I love -- I love when they say,
"I answered your question"
as if it's a Jedi mind trick.
[ Laughter ]
"These are not the answers
you're looking for."
[ Laughter ]
In another revealing exchange,
Haspel was pressed
on whether she would follow
an order from President Trump
to illegally waterboard
a detainee,
and her immediate answer
was not reassuring.
-If the CIA has
a high-value terrorism suspect
in its custody,
and the President gave you
a direct order to waterboard
that suspect,
what would you do?
-Senator, I would advise --
I do not believe the President
would ask me to do that.
-First of all, moving forward,
no one is allowed to say,
"I do not believe
the President would..."
[ Laughter ]
...followed
by any terrible thing.
If you don't believe --
[ Applause ]
If you don't believe
the President would shove a nun,
you're not trying hard enough
to envision a situation where
a nun would be in his way.
[ Laughter ]
And second of all,
did you miss this?
-I would
bring back waterboarding,
and I'd bring back
a hell of a lot worse
than waterboarding.
If I say, "Do it,"
they're gonna do it.
That's what leadership
is all about.
-No. "If I say, 'Do it,'
they're gonna do it"
is not leadership.
That's the Westminster Dog Show.
[ Laughter ]
And now, to be fair
to President Trump,
President Obama also nominated
a CIA Director, John Brennan,
who was a defender of torture,
so this isn't unique to Trump.
It's something we all have
to eventually reckon with.
And while Trump's
nominee for CIA director
was refusing to disavow her role
in an illegal torture program,
Trump was also busy violating
the Iran nuclear deal.
Trump has long railed
against the Iran deal,
but he doesn't actually have a
coherent argument against it.
All he does
is mock the people who wrote it,
like former
Secretary of State John Kerry.
Kerry famously
got in a cycling accident
while he was
negotiating the deal,
and that's apparently
the one thing
Trump knows about it,
because he keeps mentioning it
over and over,
as he did yet again
at an NRA conference last week.
-The former administration...
[ Audience booing ]
...as represented
by John Kerry...
[ Audience booing ]
Not the best negotiator
we've ever seen.
He never walked away
from the table
except to be
in that bicycle race
where he fell and broke his leg.
That's the only...
[ Laughter ]
I said, "Don't tell him
you broke your leg.
Just stay inside, say
you don't want to negotiate.
You'll make a much better deal."
[ Laughter ]
But he broke his leg.
And I learned from that,
at 73 years old,
you never go into bicycle race.
Okay, just don't.
-Yeah, I don't think
anyone was worried
you'd get into a bicycle race.
[ Laughter ]
Mostly because
they don't allow golf carts.
[ Laughter ]
It is so, so Donald Trump
that he keeps harping
on Kerry breaking his leg.
Trump is like the guy
you went to high school with
who never forgets
your most embarrassing moment.
You see him
at a reunion and say,
"Hey, there -- Dale McCaffrey.
I sat behind you in math."
"I remember when you crapped
your pants at prom."
[ Laughter ]
"Look, everyone --
it's Crappy Dale!"
[ Laughter ]
And Trump's comments about Iran
have been mostly incoherent,
but his inner circle
has been much clearer.
They want regime change.
For example, Trump's
newest lawyer, Rudy Giuliani,
who made that
very clear over the weekend
in a speech he gave to opponents
of the Iranian regime.
-We've got a president
who's tough,
a president who doesn't listen
to the people who are naysayers,
and a president
that is as committed
to regime change as we are.
-Why is the President's lawyer
giving foreign-policy speeches?
The highest job
he ever held was mayor.
His idea of foreign policy
was having lunch
with the mayor of Hoboken.
[ Laughter ]
Also, if anyone should be
worried about regime change,
it's Rudy Giuliani.
Based on how things are going,
I guess he has a week left
in his job, tops.
When he goes on Fox News,
they should introduce him as
the Season Finale
of Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
And Giuliani...
[ Applause continues ]
Giuliani is not the only one
of Trump's associate's
who has openly called
for regime change.
Just take Trump's
National Security Adviser,
John Bolton,
who said this just last year.
-The declared policy
of the United States of America
should be the overthrow
of the Mullah's regime
in Tehran.
-Now I don't know if Trump will
actually listen to John Bolton,
but there's hope,
because as you may recall,
Trump was originally reluctant
to hire Bolton,
not because of his insane
foreign-policy ideas
but because of Bolton's
brush-like mustache,
with one associate saying,
"Donald was not going
to like that mustache."
[ Laughter ]
So if Trump is thinking
of taking Bolton's advice
on Iran,
I would just like to say,
"Mr. President,
look at that mustache."
[ Laughter ]
Can you really trust a guy
with a mustache like that?
He looks like evil Mark Twain.
[ Laughter ]
John Bolton is Dark Twain.
He looks like
he walked into a barbershop
and said, "Give me
half a Wilford Brimley."
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump is surrounding himself
with people who made clear
they want regime change in Iran,
which undercuts
one of the central claims
of Trump's presidential campaign
that he -- he --
was the anti-war candidate.
As you might recall,
he repeatedly
went out of his way
to claim, falsely,
that he was opposed
to the Iraq war,
which he said, over
and over again, was a disaster.
-George Bush made a mistake.
We can make mistakes.
But that one was a beauty.
We should've never been in Iraq.
We have destabilized
the Middle East.
They lied. They said there were
weapons of mass destruction,
there were none,
and they knew there were none.
Look at the mess we have.
We've destabilized the
Middle East, and it's a mess.
Had we not done anything,
had our politicians gone to
the beach and enjoyed the sun,
we would be in a lot better
position than we are right now.
What we've done is incredible.
If we would've --
If our presidents
would've just stayed home
and gone to the beach
or even gone out
and played golf,
every single day,
played two rounds a day --
okay? --
which Obama almost does.
-Obama played two rounds a day?
Trump plays so much golf,
I wouldn't be surprised
if he played during meetings.
[ Laughter ]
"Rudy, open wide.
Hole in one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hole in one."
[ Applause ]
And yet Trump and his allies
are now repeating
the same mistakes
that got us into the Iraq war
that he claimed to oppose.
Last week, for example,
the Trump administration
issued a stunning warning,
claiming that
"Iran has a robust,
clandestine
nuclear-weapons program."
Now the key word there is "has."
The Trump administration
seemed to be saying
that Iran currently has
a secret ongoing
nuclear program right now.
In other words, they're saying
Iran has WMDs.
If that were true,
it would be massive news.
But it quickly turned out
it was a mistake.
-One single word
in a White House statement
set off
a barrage of alarm and questions
about Iran's nuclear capability.
The initial statement
said that Iran "has" --
present tense --
a robust, clandestine
nuclear-weapons program.
An updated statement,
sent a couple of hours later,
read Iran "had" -- past tense --
such a program.
The White House claims
that was a "clerical error."
-Wow, that is a hell of a typo.
That's like your doctor saying,
"You have 40 days to live.
Whoops! Sorry --
years, 40 years."
[ Laughter ]
So it was a one-letter typo,
which is no small thing.
If we're not careful,
we could end up invading
Iraq again by accident.
[ Laughter ]
And something tells me
the Trump tweet about that
will be short.
[ Laughter ]
Trump is repeating
the same mistakes that got us
into the Iraq war,
and he's being cheered on
by many of the same people
who orchestrated that war.
In fact, the only lesson Trump
seems to have learned is...
-You never
go into a bicycle race.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]